it's like you'll called each other to
match like today that's it the Scots us
yes the the Scott is rubbing off on you
like home yes you are amazingly
beautiful pregnant that does not happen
for all of us that is amazing how which
baby is this baby number three and done
I told the doctor I was like take
everything out that you need to take out
so I said that on my second one and then
she said did she tell you um well it
just depends on how much like whatever I
don't going get graphic but it depends
on like things what and I was like girl
if I get out of here and I have tubes in
this body we're going to have a problem
was like yeah cuz I feel like some some
of us you could just like and you get
pregnant that's that's yeah well I
didn't honestly think we could my fiance
and I were talking about it I'm like
listen I've had multiple miscarriages
and I'm about to be 40 so I'm you know I
I didn't know in our the first month
trying oh my God it's powerful it can be
powerful do you have like gotish power
when are you yeah there you go he's like
yes
yes so so are you feeling good are you
your due dates is it soon four weeks oh
my gosh what are you doing here gosh and
exactly do you know how to deliver a
baby I was like I was having
contractions back there I was like just
Brax and Hicks we're fine oh my gosh but
are you feeling okay no girl I'm ready
like we're like I was I was like hey
baby run up like it's time get out yeah
a and then you get the skin on skin my
friend just had a baby and I'm like I
keep texting about skin on skin time I
love that time it's it's that's that's
the piece where I just I just want to
see what he looks like and just hold on
it's a it's a beautiful thing that we've
created something that I didn't think
this would be our my story What a
Beautiful Surprise as
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you guys
y'all have a great night I'm going
home